have you even seen or saved a nude photo
[Laughter]
hi I'm jasmine and made the shocking
Christians hello
how much Capaldi and these are my
shocking answers all right yep
oh you definitely have done this have
you paid in the shower in the last year
but penis show in the last forever which
famous musicians music do you hate the
most
I think as musicians we should all step
together and I just don't like it when
we do I mean people put effort under
that and I just think to even ask that
question to the sketch lovely do you
stand up sit down when your wife and I
really want it I really want to explain
it like and all people say that you
shouldn't stand up because it congeals
and it's like peeling back like a okay
feel about like I'd like a toast with
chocolate we Nutella on fire if
anybody's watching right I know again I
know this is maybe fun stop [ __ ] sand
down and wiping your ass and [ __ ] add
the shoes go with OC and Dawn weight
towards your genitals right a whole
album about them and then and hasn't
never call you back well you go answer
but I felt like it was Jewish shot yeah
well we just met some things I put
[ __ ] I put my belly button my finger
my belly button and I'll give our sniff
is a very it is a very good that's a
very good gauge of leg how bad do I
smell
when did you lose your virginity I lost
over generate well yeah so yeah I'm
really happy when I was at my senpai at
my friend's house yep no that was one
that's maybe a bit too far listen if you
could become the biggest down world
fellow Scot Calvin Harris would never
sell another record would you do it it
doesn't have to so yes I have never met
a famous person who's full of [ __ ]
but I'd like to punch like Anthony
Joshua but only if it was like we'd
agreed beforehand right yep
when was the last time you had sex
well canal I was definitely in the last
seven days
what is your tender bio and I'd say I'm
on tender almost scored top ban on
soccer I am and then it says I have one
dog and I am very good at fighting which
celebrity would you most want to go on a
date with I think I've never like to go
on a date with someone like Jon Hamm is
a guy he's gonna look after you
basically he should be the captain
though sexual he's gonna take care yeah
and after what the thing is just gonna
hold me and my boys just gonna have a
really really came together when was the
last time you were romantically turned
down by someone and tell us the story
I don't know doesn't doesn't happen very
much okay be kind be Kate have you ever
seen her saved a nude photo I have never
sent an AFOL because it's a [ __ ] war
fully unimpressive piece of work that
I've got going on limit no one's gonna
look at that and go that looks
appetizing I have definitely I have
received nude photos on occasion because
s 2019 well we've got to the end of the
questions thank you thank you very much
we'll just do one for the road I'm Liz
Capaldi Jasmine he is my biggest fan and
these were my shocking answers yep of
course
that's big red button that shocking huh
not a man lying in the
you